in the ground now
get on the ground get on the ground on
the ground now on the ground on the
ground I'm gonna tell you get on the
ground get on the ground on the ground
on the ground now illegal on the ground
on the ground on the ground put it on
your face
get on the ground get on the ground get
on the ground hey get on the ground get
on the ground now please she pregnant
bro and I really haven't even done
nothing my car's apart
listen
ing
record you see Brooke I am done give me
my bag
before you go back to the car all right
490 forever
come on call Legit everything gonna be
legit all got nothing illegal on me
everything legit
stop
what you need me to do call my Mom hello
my apology
everything I ain't doing nothing what's
playing everything man
what's your name
exactly you ran right now
I'm scared as hell okay I don't know
what I don't know all right what's your
name man I'm not saying that to my
mother call my lawyer because I ain't
done nothing
to gym my college did everything y'all
just pulled up on me just hop out on me
of course I'm scared I'm scared as hell
okay
illegal
[Music]
out on me
the tattoo yeah okay
[Applause]
I'm pretty fast
[Applause]